tell me how you felt how did the phone
call go
well it's sort of one of those phone
calls you think is someone having me off
because I would have never in a thousand
years believed it would be possible and
I feel so honored and when I told my
daughter because we actually play with
Barbies at home with my 12 year old
daughter and we were bouncing around the
room I can't believe this so it's like
hi is that Maggie hi Maggie yeah it's
Mattel on the phone it was like that who
was yes we were thinking of honoring You
by creating your own Barbie yeah really
because when I was growing up I played
with Barbies but they didn't really look
like me and so now to have one that
actually looks like me it's just quite
mind-boggling but yeah a real honor oh
my goodness because some people would
say oh you know it's a bit girly but
it's not good it's about empowering
women isn't it and I think it's showing
girls that they can do anything they set
their mind to they have the potential to
change the world and I think that's a
message we need to get out more
um I do lots of public speaking and
speaking to sort of girls and kids in
general and asking them to reach for the
stars to have a big crazy dream and this
I would never dream that this would
happen but yes a crazy streams can come
true oh wow and can other people get a
copy of it or is it
just for you that's a shame isn't it
because there are others that will death
will definitely want to buy I would want
to purchase that tell me why and tell me
about your work and why you think that
you found yourself in this position very
well deserved by the way oh thank you
well um over the past sort of 18 years
I've been going out and speaking to
mainly kids but I think I'm speaking to
about 450 000 people and it's trying to
encourage girls especially to have a I
like to call it the desire to Aspire and
it's sort of that's one of the things
that Bobby is trying to show us that and
with the different dolls you think it'll
be a marine biologist you can be an
astronaut there are all these different
sort of things we can do but some girls
feel they're limited that they they
can't achieve or literally Reach for the
Stars so it's encouraging them to have
big crazy dreams and see how far they
can take them tell us what it is that
you do for those people a few people out
there who don't know it so I'm a space
Scientist by trade
oh yes so I work on things like the
James Webb Space Telescope oh amazing
yeah so I was one of the 10 000
scientists that worked on that I've also
worked on sort of satellites that help
us understand climate change but as a
space scientist I also work on
ground-based astronomy so big wonderful
telescopes that look deep into the
universe but much of what I do is
actually looking at our planet and
understanding how our planet works and
trying to tackle things like climate
change understand how our planet can
evolve in the future and to make the
world a better place for everyone and
what took you in that direction what
sort of um studying did you need to do
yes well it's funny for me because I got
the spacebug when I was really young and
I went to 13 different schools when I
was growing up yes sometimes kids say oh
my goodness you must be really naughty
but it wasn't actually like that my
parents split up when I was four and
sometimes I was with my mum sometimes I
was with my dad and so the school was
just sort of racked up and also I have a
condition called dyslexia which when you
first start out at school makes it
really hard and so I was put in the
remedial class
um but um because I have this desire to
get into space it means you can sort of
overcome hurdles and I see dyslexia now
as my superpower because it helps me
communicate my ideas and communicate
sometimes complex science to a general
audience uh but yes and so I had to put
up a rocky start but then I went on to
get a degree in physics and a PhD in
mechanical engineering and then
[Laughter]
this is why I'm Dr Mackey now but I
think that's the key is that desire to
Aspire and that's what we want to sort
of send the message out with the Barbies
uh to all the girls out there have a big
crazy dream see where it takes you and
where's your crazy dream taking you next
time well my ultimate goal now I've got
my own Barbie that's what you're taking
the Box big tick but I've always wanted
to get out into space and visit the moon
for instance yeah and that's how we're
talking about sending people back to the
moon and so far it's only been sort of
12 guys on all white and All-American so
they're talking about Mexico 1979 or 172
way 72 yeah so it's been over 50 years
yeah so they're talking about a project
Artemis sending people back to the moon
and I'm an absolute lunatic I absolutely
love the moon so yeah that's one of my
crazy dreams out there just to get into
space really so it was 69 to 72 wasn't
it we've not been there since no you're
gonna go you're definitely gonna go I
can tell and thank you for bringing in
your Barbie does she have a name or is
she just called Barbie mini Maggie
Millie Maggie I love it it's good to see
you thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate it